[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be discussing 10 more of the
darkest moments of the Harry Potter
series that were left out of the films
if you haven't watched part one of this
series go and check it out afterwards
now on to today's picks four darkest
moments that never made it from page to
screen Bill Weasley's disfigurement in
the aftermath of Dumbledore's death
Snape the werewolf finra grow back and
the group of Voldemort's Death Eaters
flee Hogwarts Castle but as they attempt
to get away fighting ensues between
those same Wizards and a group of Order
of the Phoenix members of course one of
those Wizards involved is you guessed it
Bill Weasley who in the novel barely
walks away from this fight a rather
stark contrast to the movie after being
viciously attacked by the werewolf
fenrick roback Bill's face is absolutely
destroyed to the point that his injuries
are defined by Harry as being grotesque
as a relatively minor character in the
movies I guess it's no surprise that the
film adaptation of the Half-Blood Prince
didn't portray this much goryer detail
with Bill only sustaining a few rather
insignificant scars on his face instead
in the movie it's all rather glossed
over really in the book however we're
given all the gruesome details after
Bill's encounter with fenrir Harry
looked over Hermione's shoulder and saw
an unrecognizable face lying on Bill's
pillow so badly slashed and ripped that
he looked at grotesque in fact this is
the scene that prompts Bill's fiancee
the enchantingly beautiful Fleur de la
core to announce I'm beautiful enough
for the both of us which makes a lot
more sense due to how much more horrific
Bill's disfigurement is in the novel
bharti current senior's murder while
it's true that we learn about Barty
Crouch senior's murder in the Goblet of
Fire movie The Details surrounding his
death are not all that clear in fact the
audience only sees a glimpse of body
senior's lifeless body without any
further information other than the fact
that the murderer is believed to be his
son Barty crunch Jr compare this to the
disturbing description we get of his
murder provided by a party crunch Junior
himself in the book I killed my father
no welled winky Master Barty Master
Barty what is he saying you killed your
father Dumbledore said in the same soft
voice what did you do with the body
carried it into the forest covered it
with the invisibility cloak Dumbledore
told me to go and look for my father I
went back to my father's body watched
the map when everyone was gone I
transfigured my father's body he became
a bone I buried it while wearing the
invisibility cloak in the freshly dug
Earth in front of Hagrid's cabin the
insane smile at his features once more
and his head drooped onto his shoulder
as winky wailed and sobbed at his side
next what a psychopath Hermione holding
Rita Skeeter captive in the Goblet of
Fire Rita later as the nosy reporter who
loves a good sensationalized story
pursuing story after story that taints
Harry's name and reputation the movie
version of this installment shows her to
be a rather irritating character to say
the least however we never really see
anyone do much about this which is
distinctly different from the actions of
Hermione in the book in which the Bright
Young witch who fears expulsion worse
than death not only Breaks the Rules she
breaks the law capturing Rita Skeeter in
the form of a beetle and holding her
hostage in a jar you see Rita Skeeter it
turns out was actually an unregistered
animagus and could transform undetected
into an insect oh Rita hasn't written
anything at all since the third task
said Hermione in an oddly constrained
voice as a matter of fact she added her
voice now trembling slightly Rita's Gita
isn't going to be writing anything at
all for a while not unless she wants me
to spill the beans on her nope you see
Rita Skeeter Hermione's voice trembled
with quiet Triumph is an unregistered
animagus she can turn Hermione pulled a
small sealed glass jar out of her bag
into a beetle your kidding said run you
haven't please not no I'm not said
Hermione beaming I caught her on the
windowsill in the hospital Wing look
very closely and you'll notice the
markings around her antenna are exactly
like those foul glasses she wears the
money took the glass jar back from Ron
and smiled at the beetle which buzzed
angrily against the glass I've told her
I'll let her out when we get back to
London said Hermione I've put an
unbreakable charm on the jar you see so
she can't transform and I've told her
she's to keep her quilled to herself for
a whole year see if she can't break the
habit of writing horrible lies about
people what's most disturbing about this
turn of events in the novel is what it
reveals about Hermione's darker
instincts and the pleasure she gets from
keeping Rita Skeeter held captive in a
jar and preventing her from returning to
her human form of course she means to
eventually let her out but realistically
Rita could have died in there and it all
just seems a little unsettling to me
Voldemort setting Neville's head of
flame in the final movie of the series
we witnessed Neville become a hero
several times over with his ultimate Act
of Bravery being when he stops nagini
Voldemort's beloved pet snake and final
Hawk rugs from killing Ron and Hermione
by beheading her with the Sword of
Gryffindor sadly in the film the context
of what happens here is completely lost
where did Neville come from and how in
Merlin's beard did he get the sword
well for those of you who've read the
book you know that he actually pays
quite the price to retrieve the Sword of
Gryffindor after standing up to
Voldemort and rejecting his invitation
to become a high-ranking Death Eater
Neville is made a spectacle by the dark
lord who not only paralyzes him he sets
its entire head on fire he pointed his
wand at Neville who grew rigid and still
then forced the Hat onto Neville's head
so that it slipped down below his eyes
Neville here is now going to demonstrate
what happens to anyone foolish enough to
continue to oppose me said Voldemort and
with the flick of his wand he caused the
Sorting Hat to burst into flames screams
split the Dawn and Neville was a flame
rooted to the spot unable to move and
Harry could not bear it the death of
Bertha jawkins in the Goblet of Fire
film the dark lord learns about the
upcoming trial was a tournament through
Peter Pettigrew and Barty Crouch Jr and
devises his plan to capture Harry Potter
from the information these two wizards
provide in the book however it's the
character of Bertha jawkins who's
completely removed from the plotland of
the film who spills the details of the
tournament and then pays the ultimate
price for having that information which
tragically results in her utterly
disturbing murder after brutalizing her
body and mind in order to break the
memory charm that had been placed on her
Bertha was too damaged for the dark lord
to possess so instead he did what he was
known to do when people lost their value
to him he murdered her Helena
ravenclaw's full history in the second
installment of the Deathly Hallows we
learned that Hogwarts Ravenclaw goes to
the gray lady is none other than
founding member Rowena ravenclaw's
daughter Helena Ravenclaw and while
Harry's encounter with Rowena is
certainly a little spooky in the movie
It's nowhere near as dark as her full
history that she shares with Harry in
the novel for in the book we get a far
more extensive and much darker account
of what happened to Helena after she
stole her mother's diadem and ran away
then my mother fell ill fatally ill in
spite of my perfidy she was desperate to
see me one more time she sent a man who
had long loved me though I spurned his
advances to find me she knew that he
wouldn't rest until he had done so Harry
waited she drew a deep breath and threw
back her head he tracked me to the
forest where I was hiding when I refused
to return with him he became violent the
baron was always a hot tempered man
furious at my refusal jealous of my
freedom he stabbed me the baron do you
mean the Bloody Baron yes said the gray
lady and she lifted aside the cloak she
wore to reveal a single dark wound in
her white chest when he saw what he had
done he was overcome with remorse he
took the weapon that had claimed my life
and used it to kill himself all these
centuries later he wears his chains as
an act of penitence as he should she
added basily peeves the Poltergeist and
his darker instincts peeps apologized
was glaringly absent from the Harry
Potter movies and while much of his
behavior would have added to the lighter
side of the films there are also many
darker instincts within peeves that were
left out of the movies as a result
throughout the books peeps typically
played fairly harmless pranks on
students and teachers alike with filch
the Castle's caretaker being a
particularly favored Target however some
of his practical jokes were a little
more on the alarming side for example in
the Order of the Phoenix he gleefully
chases Professor Umbridge off school
grounds as he beats her with both a
walking stick and a sock full of chalk
considering Umbridge literally tortured
students during her time as the
professor against the dark arts I
suppose this send-off wasn't all that
unsettling but then again he didn't just
save this type of behavior for sadistic
teachers in fact there were more than
one occasion in which peeves was violent
towards students jeopardizing both their
safety and their lives during Harry's
time at Hogwarts one of peeve's main
targets was Neville Longbottom forcing
the board to set his own pants on fire
and dropping objects on his head as he
tried to walk to class although always
portrayed lightly these acts were clear
representations of peeve's inclinations
towards violence his behavior in 1876 is
yet another example of his violent
nature when the caretaker that year
rankara's carp attempted to capture
peeves it did not go well at all with
peeves escaping the Trap and going on an
epic Rampage around the castle firing
off crossbows guns and a small cannon
and students which resulted in the
school's three-day evacuation
Dumbledore's dark past in the films we
only briefly hear of Professor
Dumbledore's dark past with much of his
relationship with garlic Grindelwald and
Views as a young wizard left out in the
Deathly Hallows book however we hear
firsthand from Dumbledore about his more
Disturbing Behavior in his youth in
particular he explains how he was
incredibly arrogant believing his
talents to be wasted as his younger
sister's Guardian after the death of
both his parents while this is rather
disappointing it's not all that dark his
thoughts regarding Muggles however are
in a rather disturbing admission
Dumbledore acknowledges to Harry that as
a young man he believed that humans
should be subjugated and ruled by
witches and wizards believing magical
beings to be a superior race Grindelwald
you cannot imagine how his ideas caught
me Harry and flamed me Muggles forced
into subservience we Wizards triumphant
grindel will deny the Glorious young
leaders of the Revolution creature's
tale of regulus black staff there's a
much more in-depth description of the
death of Sirius Black's younger brother
regulus in the Deathly Hallows novel
when compared to the films with the
black family's house elf creature
explaining the dark details of exactly
what happened to his former Masters in
the book The rather miserable house self
explains that after pledging himself as
a Death Eater at the age of just 16
regulus inevitably had a change of
hearts and no longer wanted to serve the
dark lord instead after learning of
Southern's locket its role as a horcrux
and Voldemort's hiding place for it
regulus goes after it intent on
destroying it at any cost regulars
Ventures to the cave with creature
drinks the potion takes the locket
replacing it with a replica and gives
the real thing to creature ordering the
household to return home without him as
you can imagine regulus does not survive
this ordeal and creature last sees him
being dragged underwater by the inferior
to his death but not before he had left
a note for Voldemort to find in the fake
locket to the dark lord I know I'll be
dead long before you read this but I
want you to know that it was I who
discovered your secrets I have stolen
the real horcrux and intend to destroy
it as soon as I can I face death in the
hope that when you meet your match you
will be mortal once more r a b the
attack on Ariana Dumbledore the highly
disturbing past of Albus Dumbledore's
younger sister is not a subject that's
really touched on in the films while the
movies do provide us with the context
that Ariana was kept somewhat hidden
from the public due to her ailing Health
they never really get into the why of
Ariana's rather odd situation but in the
books much more detail is provided and
it's certainly on the darker side of
things for not only do we come to know
that Ariana Dumbledore was killed around
the age of 14 during a disagreement gone
wrong between Albus his brother
aberforth and Gaelic Grindelwald we also
learned how her condition came to be in
the death of Novel it's revealed that
she was attacked as a small girl no more
than six years old by a group of muggle
boys after witnessing her do magic they
tormented her to the point that she
became traumatized Beyond recovery many
speculate that this attack may have even
been quite physical in nature which
would explain why their father Percival
Dumbledore went after the boys an act
which resulted in Percival being sent to
Azkaban and with that we've come to the
end of another video what did you think
do you agree with my picks did I miss
any dark moments from the books that are
left out of the films please share your
thoughts in the comments below and as
always if you enjoyed this video don't
forget to like it and subscribe to the
channel also be sure to check out the
content on Spotify as well as extra
content on my second Channel Harry
Potter Theory extra until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live